President Trump has made decisions about  clemency for three US service members  they are an executive grant of clemency  a full pardon for former first  lieutenant Clint Lawrence who was  convicted of second-degree murder for  ordering his soldiers to open fire and  kill three men in Afghanistan former  Army Major Matthew Goldstein who accused  of murdering at Taliban bomb-maker and  Navy SEAL  Eddie Gallagher was reinstated to his  previous rank before his trial when he  was acquitted of wounding Isis detainee  but found guilty of a lesser charge  taking a photograph with a separate dead  Isis fighter all three of them now full  pardon clemency Steve what about this  what are the details of each of this  story so I won't attempt to weigh in on  the on the details on one whether it  makes sense or not but certainly this is  something that President Trump has shown  an interest in in the past he's it's  something that will no doubt please this  political base